hello there
in this video we will explain why many
dimensions
can be both a blessing and a curse
when doing machine learning so it's miss
coffee bean here with a video about some
important basics in machine learning
first we have to explain what are
dimensions and why do we need them
in machine learning the number of
dimensions describes the number of
coordinates we have to give
in order to fully localize a point
for example we have one dimension if we
only need
one coordinate to find the point like
this point on this line
for two dimensions we already need two
numbers to localize one point
three dimensions are very normal to us
because space around us
is three-dimensional and to localize an
object we have to specify three points
but the spatial dimensionality in
particular
does not limit dimensionality in general
dimensions can be anything especially in
machine learning problems
for example to characterize a data point
like
a rocket we might need a dimension where
we specify
its speed we can specify the rocket's
weight
in a second dimension its height in a
third dimension
and so on in some machine learning
contexts
it is quite common to use the word
dimension as a synonym for feature
and theoretically nothing stops us to
increase the number of dimensions or
features to infinity
we take whatever we can to characterize
a point
because these features can be then used
by a machine learning algorithm
to differentiate points one from another
but what do high dimensional spaces
bring with them
a large number of dimensions can be a
blessing
think about problems that are not
linearly separable
in low dimensions so cases in which we
cannot
just draw a line to separate our data
with for example linear regression
but certain mappings to higher
dimensions
can make data linearly separable so
very easy to solve however helpful in
these cases
many dimensions can quickly become a
curse
to visualize we have two points a
and b in only one dimension to compute
the distance between the two
we just have to compute the difference
between their coordinates
done in two dimensions the distance
computations become a little more
difficult
since we now have more coordinates for
our points
and if we assume that the points lie on
the diagonal
of a cube forming a 45 degree angle with
both axes then the distance simplifies a
little
it becomes the difference between the
coordinates in one
of the dimensions say x multiplied by
the square root of
two and two happens to be the number of
dimensions
we observe the same pattern in one
dimension
where the difference of the coordinates
is virtually
multiplied by square root of one which
is again
our number of dimensions the same holds
also for
three dimensions where the distance
between diagonal corner points of the
cube
scales with square root of three
and here we generalize without
delivering the proof
now that the distance between such
points a
and b is proportional to the square root
of the number of dimensions d
what does this mean well it means that
in
a high number of dimensions there is a
lot of space to begin with
so we have a lot of new places to put
points
into since the distance between them is
bigger with each added dimension
when distances increase it also means
that the overall volume
of the space increases so that we need
many more points to sample the space
with the same density
for one dimension it might be enough to
sample only two points but in two
dimensions one needs
four points to fill a grid with the same
interval
and already eight points in three
dimensions to be precise with each
dimension
we need exponentially more points to
populate the space
oh no what do we do high dimensional
spaces are like a two-sided
coin on the one side high dimensions are
a blessing for
linear separability on the other side of
the coin there is
a curse many dimensions increase the
overall volume of the space
so points and machine learning
optimizers can get
lost inside the void of high
dimensionality
so what do we do there are ways to
decrease dimensionality
and in the next video we will explain
how dimensionality reduction works
can't wait are you still here go
and do not let the dark side of
dimensionality take over
see you bye
[Music]
you